digamos que quieres saber cuál es la
división de 5.600 entre 8 y bueno
seguramente vas a querer hacer esto
poner por aquí 5600 entre la casita de
la división poner aquí el 8 y hacer esta
división larga y eso está súper bien vas
a usar bastante papel pero resulta que
hay un truco mucho más sencillo para
resolver esta división y el truco
consiste en darse cuenta de que aquí
tenemos dos ceros lo que hay porque como
aquí tenemos dos ceros entonces este
número de aquí es simplemente 56% y
queremos dividir entre 8 56% es 5600
aunque hay aquí tenemos dos ceros y aquí
tenemos dos ceros déjame lo hago todavía
más claro tenemos aquí 2
y tenemos aquí dos ceros
ok 5.600 es igual a 56% y bueno una vez
que ya lo escribiste así 56% entre 8
entonces podemos cambiar el orden de la
multiplicación y la división podemos
ponerlo así 56 lo vamos a poner por aquí
56 después vamos a poner entre 8
entre 8 y finalmente ponemos por 100%
ahora para que hicimos esto pues porque
si te fijas aquí 56 entre 8 si te
acuerdas muy bien de las tablas de
multiplicar aquí ya sabes exactamente
cuánto vale esta división aunque porque
8 por 7 56 entonces 56 entre 87 y ya lo
único que nos falta es averiguar cuánto
vale 7% y 7% pero esto son 7 cientos o
sea 707 cientos
y listo ahora vamos a hacer más
ejercicios como estos en los que tenemos
una división larga que podríamos
resolver fácilmente usando papel pero
que si lo partimos en pedazos como lo
hicimos aquí tal vez podemos resolver la
división utilizando mucho menos papel de
una forma mucho más fácil e incluso
hasta podríamos hacerlo en la cabeza
digamos que ahora tenemos el número 846
y queremos dividir ese número entre 2 y
el truco para hacer esta división de una
forma muy fácil tan fácil que lo podrías
hacer en tu cabeza es tomar el 846 y
dividirlo en pedacitos ok
porque tenemos que 846 lo podemos
dividir como 800 más 40
46 más 6
tenemos 8 centenas 4 decenas y 6
unidades y aquí igual tenemos 8 centenas
4 decenas y 6 unidades y queremos
dividir a este número
este número entre 2
entre dos no hicimos nada extraño este
paréntesis de aquí
es exactamente igual a este otro
paréntesis de aquí y bueno ya que lo
tenemos escrito de esta forma que tal
vez estas cajitas nos distraen un poco y
entonces las vamos a quitar
pero ya que tenemos a esta división
escrita de esta forma lo que podemos
hacer es simplemente distribuir este
entre dos adentro del paréntesis ok
seguramente estás acostumbrado a hacer
esto con la multiplicación pero también
se puede hacer con la división si
distribuimos el entre dos adentro del
paréntesis lo que nos queda es esto
tenemos 800 entre 2 800 entre 2 más 40
entre 2 más 40 entre 2 y muy pronto voy
a poner paréntesis para que quede más
claro pero ya nada más nos falta poner
más 6 entre 2 y más
entre dos aunque hay tenemos 800 entre 2
aquí está 800 entre 2 que también son 8
centenas entre dos también tenemos 40
entre 2 aquí está el 40 entre 2 o sea 4
decenas entre 2 y finalmente 6 entre 2
aquí está el 6 entre 2 que son 6
unidades entre 2 ok lo que hicimos tal
cual fue distribuir el entre 2 adentro
del paréntesis y aquí nada más tenemos
que hacer estas divisiones que son súper
sencillas aunque hay 800 entre 2 es 408
centenas de la mitad son 4 centenas 40
entre 2 es 20 4 decenas entre 2 son dos
decenas y finalmente 6 unidades entre
dos es 3
este es el resultado de nuestra división
de 420 20 3
y bueno yo utilicé un montón de pantalla
para que tú dijeras muy bien exactamente
qué es lo que estaba pasando pero en
realidad no tienes que escribir todo
esto de aquí aunque puedes hacerlo super
sencillo en tu cabeza desde aquí aunque
sí tenemos 846 y lo queremos dividir
entre dos lo único que tienes que hacer
es decir ok tenemos ocho centenas 800
dividido entre dos esos son cuatro
centenas o cuatrocientos y luego tenemos
cuatro decenas que a la mitad son dos
decenas y finalmente tenemos seis
unidades que entre dos son tres unidades
y listo ya tenemos aquí 423
pero en realidad aunque aquí lo hagamos
súper sencillo lo que estamos haciendo
en el fondo es esto de aquí ok se parará
el número en centenas decenas de
unidades y dividir a cada uno de esos
pedazos entre 2 y
realidad cuando hacemos estas divisiones
largas también estamos haciendo
exactamente esto que es separar al
número en valores posicionales e irlo
dividiendo pedazo por pedazo ahora vamos
a hacer uno último para asegurarnos que
siempre disfrutes hacer este tipo de
cuentas pero para eso necesitamos más
espacio digamos que tenemos 963 y
queremos dividir este número entre 9 y
en estos momentos tal vez tú te quedes
mirando a este número y digas oye yo sé
muy bien cómo dividir
algunas de estas partes de este número
entonces lo que hacemos es decir ok 963
es igual a 900 y estoy separando el 900
porque sabemos perfectamente cómo
dividir a 900 entre 9 entonces llevamos
900 y ahora puedes decir ok
aquí tenemos 63 y sabemos muy bien cómo
dividir 63 entre 9 entonces podemos
tomar lo completo ponemos por aquí 900
más 63 no necesariamente tenemos que
dividirlo todo en centenas decenas y
unidades lo que podemos tomar cachos
completos así es que 963 lo estamos
separando como 900 más 63 y queremos
dividir ese número entre 9 y aquí lo que
nos queda es 900 entre 9 900 entre 9 más
63 entre 9 63 entre 9 ok
aquí lo único que hice fue distribuir el
entre 9 adentro del paréntesis
y 900 entre 9 son 100 mientras que 63
entre 9 son 7 sumamos estos dos números
y nos queda 107 y listo ya terminamos
ahora otra vez escribimos todo esto de
aquí cuando no es necesario pero cuando
tengas más práctica puede simplemente
tomar 963 y decir ok
tenemos aquí 900 que entre 9 son 100 y
luego tenemos 63 que entre 9 son 7 así
es que el resultado tiene que ser 107 y
punto bueno espero que te hayas
divertido tanto como yo pero no solo es
divertido también es súper útil
lo que hay que tal que un día sales con
tus amigos a un restaurante y tienen una
cuenta y quieren dividirse la cuenta en
partes iguales pues vas a tener que
utilizar una división como esta y te
sirve para las finanzas y para un montón
de cosas distintas y además si practicas
lo suficiente más adelante ni siquiera
vas a tener que escribir nada ni
utilizar lápiz y papel lo puedes hacer
todo en tu cabeza